the parable of the sower is probably one
of Christ's most known parables
everybody has heard that story but
there's something very interesting about
this parable because it is in a way a
meta parable it is not only a parable
that talks about a specific example of
life but it is a parable which can help
you understand parables themselves and
can help you understand meaning making
in general basically the parable of the
sower is just like so many other things
that Christ says is hiding within it the
very pattern of how reality unfolds so
we're going to look at the parable of
the sower and see if we can try to bring
out some of these aspects which connect
to the types of things that I'm talking
about in terms of symbolism and how we
encounter the world
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now the parable of the sower is in all
three of the synoptic Gospels and so
I've chosen to use the version in the
Gospel of st. mark st. mark chapter 4:1
2:25 because there's a little detail in
that version that I want to emphasize
specifically so I'm going to read the
text to you and then we're going to go
over some of the elements that Christ
talks about and I'm gonna try to show
you you know how the parable that Christ
is giving can be applied to our very
perception of reality and how it is in a
way very much a meta parable and so and
he began to teach by the sea and a great
multitude was gathered to him so that he
got into the boat and sat in it on the
sea and the whole multitude was on the
land facing the sea then he taught them
many things by parables and said to them
in his teaching listen behold a sower
went out to sow and it happened as he
sowed that some seed fell by the wayside
and the birds of the air came and
devoured it some fell on the stony
ground where it did not have much earth
and immediately it sprang up because it
had no depth of earth but when the Sun
was up it was scorched and because it
had no root it withered away and some
seed fell among thorns and the thorns
grew up and choked it and it yielded no
crop but other seed fell on ground on
good ground and yielded a crop that
sprang up increased and produced some
thirtyfold some 60 and some a hundred
and he said to them he who has ears to
hear let him hear but when he was alone
those around him with the twelve asked
him about the parable and he said to
them to you it has been given to know
the mystery of the kingdom of God but to
those who are outside all things come in
parables so that quote seeing they may
see and not perceive and hearing they
may hear and not understand lest they
should turn and their sins be forgiving
forgiving them and he said to them
do you not understand this parable how
then will you understand all the
parables the sower shows the word and
these are the ones by the wayside where
the word is sown when they hear Satan
comes immediately and takes away the
word that was sown in their hearts
these likewise are the ones sown on
stony ground who when they hear the word
immediately receive it with gladness and
they have no root in themselves and so
endure only for a time afterward when
tribulation or persecution arises for
the for the words sake immediately they
stumbled now these are the ones sown
among the thorns they are the ones who
hear the word and the cares of this
world the deceitfulness of riches and
desires for other things enter in choke
the word and it becomes unfruitful but
these are the ones sown on good ground
those who hear the word accept it and
bear fruit some thirtyfold some sixty
and some a hundred now there is a lot to
unpack in this parable Christ is
basically painting a cosmic image of how
the world works but the first thing we
need to pay attention to is a little
detail which is actually only in this
version of the parable and it is how
Christ tells his disciples do you not
understand this parable how then will
you understand all the parables and this
is the little key that I wanted to point
you to Christ is saying that this
parable is in a way a meta parable it is
a parable about parables it's a parable
it's not just about parables but it's a
parable about meaning making itself or
meaning making not in an abstract way
not just in a kind of abstract
understanding but meaning in the sense
of it's a parable of how meaning how
abstract things how ideas how concepts
essences you know I'm using different
words because it you know all of the
invisible thing
connect with the visible world and how
there's this incarnation sepulveda self
out in the world that is what Christ is
talking about and he's using a human
person as the anchor for his example and
is of course the best way to talk about
it he's talking at the level of the
human person hearing something and then
it his heart acting as the place where
this meeting of meaning and possibility
meets you know how heaven and earth meet
in the person's heart and as that
happens then we see whether or not there
this seed which falls into the ground
will give fruit now when you hear about
seed it's very important to understand
that there the relationship between seed
and heaven first of all seeds you know
they come they fall from above and they
fall on to the ground not only that but
seeds are also this they're the pattern
of a tree you know if you look at a seed
you just have this little dot but in the
little dot is contained the pattern of
the tree the tree it's a it's it's an
image of a bodyless principle of course
a seed has physical body but it has so
little body that it becomes an image of
this point the center you know the the
essence of something and so every time
you read in the scripture especially in
Christ's explanations when he talks
about a seed that's what he's talking
about something which is not not hasn't
yet borne fruit which is contained which
is just the idea or just the concept or
or you know or just the center without
the margin without the laying out of
everything else okay that's when and so
the heart itself is the place you could
say the heart itself can be the seed but
the heart is usually mostly the I'd
thrown or the place where the seed will
hit you know so the heart becomes like
the Ark of the Covenant with the glory
of God coming down and landing on the
ark and then the glory of God shining
out into the
world it's important to understand that
that this is this relationship because
if you look at right after the parent
this parable Christ uses the image of
the light which should not be hidden
under a bushel which should not be
hidden under a bucket but should which
would shine forth into the world and so
that he is relating by adding that
parable at this image after the parable
of the seed which is in the ground he's
connecting those two together and it's
helping us to understand that the the
light which shines out are the this idea
of the glory which comes down on the ark
and then shines out in the world the
seed which falls in the ground and then
produces fruit all of these are images
of the same thing so we have to look at
what are the different examples that
Christ gives in order to help you see
what are the possibilities of this
relationship that is when there is
something abstract and there is a a body
or there's something underneath which is
going to be the potential out of which
this abstract thing is taking its its
it's a capacity to exist in the world
what are the possibilities of these
connecting so he talks first of all
about this idea that the sower went out
to sow and so you can understand that at
different levels of reality you can
understand it as of course ultimately as
God you know spreading out the essences
of things that the the you know that God
speaking the world into existence he's
spreading out these seeds out into over
the ground and so imagine now go back
into Genesis think of God speaking the
world into existence these words that
come out of God's mouth are these
essences are the the names of things
okay and so a seed is can be related to
a the idea of a name that is it contains
within itself the pointing to something
you know that which gathers all these
potentiality into one thing if I point
to a chair and I'm like chair all that
that is is manifesting the unity of the
thing I'm pointing to okay so the
essences that are that are
you see that like I said in Genesis when
God creates the world that is what is
related to the sower that is spreading
out the seed spreading out the Logie
spreading out the the essences and so
some of the seeds fall on the wayside
you have to understand that they fall on
the side of a path and the birds of the
air come and devour it now Christ in his
example he says that that is the someone
who you know the the word comes to him
and when they hear it
Satan immediately comes and takes the
word away the word that's sown in their
hearts and so the word comes but right
away Satan takes it away there's no room
for it there's no place for it and so it
the idea that it falls next to the
wayside of course in practice it makes
sense that yeah see so if you put seeds
on the wayside because the earth is
already completely you know tap down and
because it's being used for as a path
then there's no place for the for the
roots to take shape but that is also
part of its meaning which is that when
something when there's already a path
when there's already a meaning it is
extremely difficult to sow a seed into
something which already has a meaning
you know now of course everything that
I'm saying doesn't take away from the
personal aspect of this a parable and I
think it's very important to insist on
that that you know of course this does
refer to hearing the good word of God
about your life and you know and and
acting on it of course it refers to that
but it can also refer to anything which
is you if you're you know I don't know
if you're if you're walking and you're
going to the store to to get some milk
and that's your purpose and you have
this this purpose that you're you're
you're doing and then as you're going
there someone will call you on your
phone and say you know would you come
over and do this and and you already
have this path that you're on you
have something that you're doing I'm
using that example but it could be
anything it could be that you're working
and you're you're you know you working
on your computer and your child comes to
you and your child says dad can you come
and do this for me and you're on the
path and so you already have a logo so
you already have a mean you haven't
already have a direction and so there's
no room for that idea to come and take
root because you already you're already
doing something in order in order for
you to be able to attend to this new
seed which is coming down upon you you
have to plough your earth you would have
to deconstruct break down what you're
doing in order to be able to reorient
your attention towards what is coming
this new seed this new idea you know and
so you can see that in all kinds of
manner that a there are some ideas that
just cannot take root in certain
societies for example because they
because they already have a way of doing
things in a way of being that there just
isn't any room for these new ideas to
take shape because they're just not they
don't fit into the path and so it's
neither good nor bad you know sometimes
it can be good sometimes it can be bad
but it's mostly the idea that as if you
there's already a path there's no room
for new ideas on that path the bird
comes down and this bird in this case is
Satan and Satan picks up the the seed
and and carries it up so what is that
what is that referring to I mean
obviously we can understand it in our
personal lives but you know how can we
understand it in terms of a pattern that
can be applied to many other things is
here you have to understand Satan as a
kind of dark principality understand it
as some a principality which is above
you but in this case is negative and is
preventing the seed from landing and in
the ground um but it doesn't necessarily
have to be dark that when you see the
idea of birds in the in the Old
Testament or in the Bible and a lot of
stories usually the birds are these
principalities that come down sometimes
the birds or the principalities that
sing
in the trees you know you understand it
as the the pattern you know the the
music of the spheres for example and so
you have this image of the birds up in
the trees that are singing and are
manifesting the patterns to us but you
can also have the idea of the bird that
comes down as a as a raptor and comes
and picks things up right and comes and
picks things up and then the
principality's appear more negatively as
something which will separate heaven and
earth and here in this case is is is an
example where the Principality will come
and pick the the idea and prevent it
from from manifesting itself in the
world now there are some examples I can
give you an example ass to really stupid
example of this happening one example is
flying cars right flying cars flying
cars have been the idea of flying cards
have been around for a hundred years and
the idea is there it's our it's always
there but because of the way the world
is set up that principality is not
landing it's constantly being picked up
and held up in the the invisible sphere
and so it still it exists as this
imaginary idea it exists as this
imaginary thing but it's never landing
in the world and finding body and so
this is there are plenty of ideas like
that that actually can't that can't land
that and some of them shouldn't land you
know for example the whole problem of
utopia is a problem is a problem of
ideal that are so high that in a way
they shouldn't actually land in the
ground because they would create
monsters so some of it's like I said
these ideas are neither negative nor
positive but there are some my
principles that get carried up or held
up high and so and so they don't land
and they're held up by the fact that
they they're more on the side of the
principality and they don't actually
they don't actually have room to have
body but that it can also be negative it
can also be that if a dark principality
is holding on to something if there's a
very if there's a dark purpose
for our society if we're held by our the
demons for example if you're held by the
passion of of hunger then a good idea a
good discipline something that could
help you that could help you get out of
this principality is going to struggle
to land in your world and and Satan the
of the opposer the divider is going to
pick that up and try to keep it up in
the fantasy world keep it up into the
idea so you can keep dreaming about the
day that you're going to diet or the day
that you're going to develop this
discipline but it's never in Satan is
constantly picking it up and not letting
it land into the your actual body well
the second example that Christ gives is
the seed which falls on stony ground and
doesn't have much earth and this seed
will grow up really quickly but then as
soon as the Sun rises the Sun will
scorch the plant and then they will
wither immediately now of course
everybody can imagine this this type of
experience we've all had this experience
where you know you you make a new year's
resolution and you're like yeah I'm
gonna do this and within a few weeks
it's gone because it doesn't it didn't
have you already have so many things to
do you already have all these other your
it's related to the idea of being on the
path it's a little bit off the path you
could say but you already have all these
meanings in your life all these things
that are good or bad just all these
purposes that you have that trying to
change them or add something might
flower up really quickly and then go
away this particular example is
extremely a good example that we see all
the time now our whole world seems to be
made out of this stony ground with
shallow earth is of course fashion
fashion is exactly this and so an idea
drops in and you know for for a year
everybody is wearing whatever
everybody's wearing you know you know
those super tight pants that everybody
was wearing like baggy baggy bottoms
it's like okay that's gonna you know
when you see it that this idea is this
extreme idea
that is very shallow that doesn't that
isn't anchored profoundly into even our
fashion our long fashion tradition in
the West and so it lands and then you
know that it's going to last for a
season and it's going to be gone because
it is it is very shallow in its kind of
extreme growing up it's it's very
shallow
fashion is probably really the best way
to understand that the same thing
happens with you know extreme musical
fashions all of these things that come
and they're gone flashed the pan they
disappear because they they are not
anchored profoundly in our culture you
can see this for example a very strong
version of this was in all the fad diets
that came extreme fad diets that came
around and are still kind of coming
around they just they just they just
come and go they appear in the disappear
because they are too different from the
usual purpose and so the idea of the Sun
coming up and shining down on the plant
and scorching them that that is the
deeper pattern that is whatever deeper
pattern is there as soon as that deeper
pattern appears then it's going to
wither up this superficial pattern
that's appearing just on the surface and
so for example I was talking about
fashion there are some deeper patterns
which seem to have set themselves up in
our society that you have a wearing a
suit and a tie let's say and then all of
a sudden there'll be some extreme thing
that's going to appear when really
really really gaudy ties we're wearing
really really thin ties maybe or really
really thick ties and so when you see
those appear you know that and when the
deeper pattern starts to shine again
that extreme version of it that that
kind of peripheral superficial excess of
it is just going to vanish and the
pattern is going to end up being more
regular and so the the suit and the tie
is going to continue but these kind of
extreme versions which appear on a very
shallow level are going to vanish under
the weight of the basic pattern okay so
that is just an example to understand it
but like I said there are plenty of
examples in all areas of your life where
this thing this type of behavior will
will appear you need to be
to it now the third example is the story
of the thorns and so the idea that the
seed is planted
but that these thorny bushes come out
and choke out the plant that's growing
and Christ talks about how it's the
distractions of the world it's our
passions it's you know it's it's the the
desire for riches and so here instead of
having this idea of a dark principality
let's say that will that will pull up
and prevent it from incarnated it's
mostly now from the outside you have
this encroachment of things from the
outside that are devouring and
preventing the body you know taking up
so much room that they're preventing the
body from actually taking shape and so
everybody has had everybody's had that
example being distracted by all kinds of
things whether it's you know you you you
have a discipline there's something that
you want to bring down into your life
but you end up just playing video games
or watching movies or or whatever it is
there's these distractions from the
outside that print that kind of suck up
your strengths suck up the potential and
prevent the seed from growing and of
course the thorns are the perfect
example now if you if you look at the
whole thing if you look at this whole
image it's very fascinating because it
actually has a powerful hierarchy in the
way that Christ describes all these
different examples and so I always tell
you about how the hierarchy the the
basic hierarchy of the Garden of Eden is
is not necessarily positive or negative
it's just the structure of reality and
so here Christ describes this reality he
starts by describing this idea of a path
which could be understood as also a
mountain like a purpose or a reason so
he had this idea of a path and a purpose
you know a road then he also talks about
stony ground or a stone which is above
the ground so it's you also have this
idea of the mountain as a path or as a
purpose and then also the problem the
idea of something which is a little
higher up like a like a stony ground
that's not completely down and then he
goes to the thorns which are in the
story of the Garden of Eden on the
outside and are you know the same thing
in the story of the Garden of Eden
they're just the the passions and the
distractions and the opposition of the
outside and so he's actually tracing the
same image as do you find in the garden
and it's it's funny it's interesting
because in this version it's it's some
of it's neither good nor bad that is if
your path if your mountain is the bad
mountain then then you won't be able to
have this renewal of having a new plant
in new and new plowed ground and so and
then he talks how he talks about the
negative aspect of the path the negative
aspect of you know the idea of the of
the being a little higher up on the
stones and then the negative aspect of
the thorns themselves on the outside he
talked about all the negative aspects of
all these all these things and then he
finally talks about the good earth and
the good earth is the one within which
all the negative principalities all the
negative things have been plowed have
been broken down and so you are in a
kind of virginal state where you're
ready to receive this new seed and to be
able to have new fruit you know baptism
is an example of this process of
breaking down all the negative
principalities all the negative patterns
in your life in order to be ready to now
start again and have a new pattern let's
say and so there's also a really
fascinating aspect to this parable which
is that Christ talks about how this is
really the parable of parables and he
links it to his disciples themselves and
so he what he's suggesting is that his
disciples are the ones who have been
plowed already they they have been
baptized they have been following Christ
and so they are the ones
who are this Good Earth and that's why
Christ talks about you know if you have
the ears to hear if you have the eyes to
see that is if you are capable if you
are prepared to see these patterns then
you will be able to see them but if
you're not then your will your will be
closed off you will be kept on the
outside and so he's applying the parable
to his disciples the the fact that
Christ then secretly tells them the
meaning of the parable is the parable
itself these are interrelated he's
trying to explain how the work of
preparing the soil is something that the
disciples have encountered and so now
they are capable of hearing the true
meaning of the parable and so the fact
that Christ explains that parable just
to his disciples is actually part of the
parable and so he's saying you who have
been prepared you my disciples you who
have now have entered into the heart
have entered into the the mystery are
now capable of perceiving the meaning of
the parable you are able to perceive the
patterns in something which to people on
the outside just appears like a just a
story that doesn't have any profound
meaning and so it's really something
that some of you that have been
following my videos for a long time I
know that you've experienced that as
well and I know that I've experienced
the same thing which is that before we
develop you know a capacity to perceive
the patterns certain stories just go
right over our heads we watch a movie we
read a story we look at we read the
Gospel story and we we just see what's
on the surface and once we start to now
engage with the world and prepare our
hearts and try to break down the
propaganda patterns that sadly we've
received as children or the very
superficial materialist atheistic
patterns that we've received as children
then all of a sudden we can see the
light
shine through the stories we can see the
light shine through the the the parable
- the parables in of all of reality and
ultimately it's fascinating because
Christ has this after the parable of the
sower Christ talks about how you know
you are the light of the world and you
have to shine in the darkness and you
would think that you know it's
fascinating because up right before he
talks about how those on the outside
will not understand it's only those on
the inside that will understand only
those that have been prepared only those
that have been so it actually looks like
a contradiction on the right right after
he says those that are outside will be
cut off you know - those who have that's
where Christ says to those who have more
and more will be given to those who have
have little it'll be taken away from
them you know this idea that the outside
is cut off that the outside because it's
not prepared because it it's not in the
heart in the mystery it can't receive
the patterns but then he says you have
to shine out in the darkness but you
really have to put those two realities
together in order to understand Christ's
full message it's often the case that if
you just take one aspect of what Christ
is saying you're usually missing out on
the bigger patterns he tends to talk in
aporia
he tends to say something and then say
almost the exact opposite just a few
verses later the greatest classical
example is when he tells st. Peter that
you know you are Peter and on this stone
I'm going to build my church and like
one verse or two verses later he says to
st. Peter get behind me Satan and so you
you really have to be able to get to see
Christ message in it's it's ensemble or
else you're going to miss out and so he
has you know when I talk about the left
hand the right hand is kind of this kind
of pattern of bringing in to the center
and then the pattern of moving out
towards the periphery this is what
Christ is doing here he is gathering his
disciples into the heart he's gathering
his disciples into the mystery and he
is revealing to them he's prepared them
he's they've gone through baptism
they've been they've been there the dark
principalities that were holding them
are being broken down and so they can
receive the glory of God you know down
on their in their hearts
imagine the glory of God coming down on
the on the Ark of the Covenant
but once that happened then we have the
radiation out towards the outside and so
he's like he's saying I am I am
gathering you into this mystery I'm
going to give you the pattern the the
secret the pattern of reality but then
once that's happened then you will
radiate out to the outside and so he is
tracing once again the very pattern of
reality of the glory coming down on the
temple and then the temple acting as a a
let's say a a beacon for the world of
the the presence of God coming down into
the altar of the the church you know
into the the chalice of communion and
then the communicants taking the this
mystery the highest mystery and then
going out into the world and remembering
remembering God and being lights in the
world outside so Christ is tracing
always always tracing the pattern of
reality and it's really important to
when you're reading scripture always
remember that we've been so ruined our
perception of Scripture has been so
ruined that we always need to remind
ourselves that every time Christ says
something he is he is speaking at the
level of the one who created the world
and you you if you expect anything less
of Christ you're going to miss out on
the things that he's saying and even you
know I'm trying to to to understand this
and explain this but I know that I'm
missing out on a huge a huge aspect of
what the scripture contains because you
know in two months I'm going to read
this passage again and it's and then
some lights are gonna go on and I'm
going to realize just how much I missed
in all these condensed phrases that
Christ uses so I hope this has been
useful to help you understand it
aspect of of the power of that is
contained in everything that Christ says
and and hopefully it'll give you some
food for thought and I will get back to
you very soon with a new video so I hope
you enjoyed this explanation its attempt
to explain the parable of the sower
don't forget that this very weekend I
will be in Boston giving a talk at the
Greek Cathedral there in Boston I will
put a link to that in the description
it's it's very inexpensive like $15 for
the day and you get two talks as well as
a tour of the church and lunch so it's
pretty amazing I'd love to see you there
I'm going to be in Seattle very soon in
May and also in Connecticut in Hartford
in June stay tuned to that specific
details will be coming but if you want
to see me there don't forget and as you
know everything I'm doing is really
thanks to your support and so you if
you're if you enjoy what I'm doing if
you want to see it grow as I develop the
website into a blog with with several
users if you want to see that happen
please consider supporting what I'm
doing you can go to my website at the
symbolic worldcom slash support and
there you will find many ways that you
can support me for those who do I offer
every month a patron only video to thank
my supporters last month it was actually
a video on witches and looking at the
witch hunts of the early modern area and
the document the hammer of witches which
was used at that time and trying to see
if there's anything useful there and
ultimately wondering if the witches
actually won in the end